-Chris and I are about to face
off in a game of Box of Lies.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now, here's how it works.
Upstage are nine mystery boxes
containing objects
no one has ever seen before.
We'll play three rounds.
Chris, why don't you pick
the first box...box...box...
[ Audience shouting ]
-Four? Four?
It's like "The Price is Right."
-All right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
There's my first hint there.
How much does the box weigh?
Seems like not much.
-125 pounds.
-I'm very strong.
-All right.
[ Humming ]
♪♪♪♪
[ Laughter ]
[ Jimmy humming ]
Okay.
♪♪♪♪
Now, you can either lie about
this or you can tell the truth.
It's up to you.
Tell me what the object is,
or you can tell me --
You can tell me
what the object --
-It's, uh -- Is this real?
-No, look at me. All right.
-This is a small...
diorama...
of little people, dwarves.
-Dwarves.
-Engaging in...
-Oh, my goodness.
-No.
-...stretching, yoga.
And...
they're all wearing hats.
[ Laughter ]
-All right,
so you're telling me --
You're telling me that
what is in front of you...
[ Laughter ]
...is a diorama of sorts,
which is something
I normally would make
in a shoe box, perhaps,
maybe when I was growing up,
which is maybe
why you thought of that,
because we have a box
and you thought of a shoe box,
and then made up a lie
about a diorama,
which makes me think,
Chris Pratt, you lie!
[ Audience cheers ]
-Sucka!
♪♪♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-Oh. That was well done.
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That was well done!
You reeled me right in, man.
That was good.
Which one we going for?
[ Audience shouting ]
Perfect. Six it is. Perfect.
Not one person yelled six.
There we go.
[ Grunting ]
-Oh, wow!
That must be very heavy!
You're trying to hide
how heavy it is.
-[ Panting ]
♪♪♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Well...
Well, I wouldn't be surprised
if you had one of these at home.
[ Laughs ]
I got to be honest.
It's a...It's a, uh...
a vibrating Jell-o mold
of Jeff Goldblum.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪♪♪
-I think you're
telling the truth.
-You were right! I am!
♪♪♪♪
How would I make that up?
I don't know how our writers
come up with these things.
-I do have one of those at home.
I have two of them, because
they're just so much fun.
All right. Chris, you're up.
-My turn.
[ Audience shouting ]
-Man, you are good at this game.
Man, oh, man.
[ Audience shouting ]
All right. I think it was heavy,
but you acted like it was light.
-[ Clears throat ]
-All right. Oh, he's not even
looking. That's interesting.
Then I'm assuming you're lying.
If you're not even
looking at it.
-I'll tell you what it is.
-This is an interesting move.
I've never seen this before.
-Ugh.
-Okay.
-Oh.
Ooh!
Is that real?
-You said that about
the last one. Okay.
-I don't think it's very nice
to do this to this thing.
Um...
Maybe it's an omnivorous, uh,
creature, but it's --
-Are you trying use big words
to trick me?
Gosh.
-It's a skull,
and it's bedazzled.
I think it might be a raccoon,
or it could be maybe a fox.
But, um...
-Is it a herbivore
or a carnivore?
-No, it's got pointy teeth.
So I think it's maybe a predator
or maybe it's something
that eats a bunch of stuff
like a raccoon
or, like, a possum or something.
-That's interesting, because
last time you lied to me.
No, you told the truth,
but you acted like you were
lying like you didn't know.
And now you're acting like,
well, you don't know.
"Oh, I don't know.
It could be a thing.
I don't know.
I've never seen teeth before."
You know?
Never seen teeth before?
-That is the most ridiculous
thing I ever heard of.
You have teeth.
You brush them every day,
in the morning and at night!
Chris Pratt,
you are telling the truth!
-Unh! No, I'm not.
-You're not.
He's a master! You are a master!
He is a master!
Chris Pratt, everybody!